welcome back to the gadget lab I am
Michael glory and i'm mat Honan and Matt
I couldn't help but noticing that
strange and unusual tablet like think we
have sitting in front of you looks like
a tablet not quite a tablet but yeah
this is the Microsoft Surface what is it
the microsoft surface with windows 8 pro
that's right yeah that's it that's
that's the microsoft surface with
windows 8 pro or as everyone who has any
basic human dignity calls it the surface
pro yeah so that's the surface pro this
is the surface or the surface RT this is
one that came out in October yeah and so
this is a little bit different actually
a lot different this runs a full version
of Windows 8 whereas that runs basically
a stripped-down version of the operating
system this also has an intel core i5
processor and it looks like a tablet but
this is really a full-fledged laptop
with a tablet form factor I see so this
this is really closer to a tablet than
anything else right it's priced like as
habits like 500 bucks that's this is I
mean if this is what we think of as a
tablet this is a mobile device it's it's
more portable you know you can use it in
bexley any situation use a tablet in
this is a little bit larger it actually
has a fan to cool off that processor
it's a little bit heavier and it's
considerably more expensive and how
expensive is it it's nine hundred
dollars for the 64 gigabyte model and a
thousand dollars to 128 gigabyte model
plus you need to buy a keyboard for it
and if you want one which you probably
do yeah and the nice keyboard is like
130 bucks yeah that's right and then the
that's the moment actual physical keys
the moment was this one from ya money
bucks so definitely recommend spending
the extra 10 bucks on the physical keys
yeah absolutely it's it's not much
thicker if you look at the two keyboard
side by side you can hardly tell a
difference but you can tell a huge
difference in your typing okay it
performs about as well as a
comparatively price laptop is that safe
to say that that's that's safe to say
that's fair to say and the I mean so
like all your windows 7 apps
on this one they want on this one this
is this only runs so called Windows
Store apps yeah absolutely by through
the windows store you can you can
download whatever you want off the
internet here and you know install and
it should work you know if you've got a
lot of applications that you want
windows applications that you want to
run on a portable this is stefan the
better bet for you it is usable as a
tablet it has a very nice sharp screen
I've found I think it's very sharp it's
not quite retina so it's not quite as
sharp or as pleasant an experience
reading it as like you know as a book as
a tablet as the as the ipad is but it is
better than the surface RT and it is
better than most laptops are the blues
scene with touching readings I mean
totally this this is this is definitely
you know kind of a tablet I mean it's
that the thing that makes it sort of not
a tablet is this vent that goes around
when the fan comes out Alexandra found
in her testing that this could get kind
of hot and uncomfortable she was holding
it for extended periods like a tablet
but if you're using its short-term like
a tablet I mean you know it's it's
you're not going to be able to tell a
whole lot of difference in and it does
come with a fancy little stylus does
this is this pin actually works really
well in phrase pressure points yeah
pressure-sensitive it supports 10-point
multi-touch so it is it is we keep
saying this because a lot of people it's
a such a weird device where it looks
like a tablet and Microsoft makes
something that looks almost exactly like
it that is also a tablet but this is a
full Windows 8 computer and you know if
you're laying out over eleven hundred
dollars on it which is what it will cost
you if you get the sky tea powder and
the 128 gigabyte version which we
definitely recommend should always get
as much storage as you can and these
devices you can't upgrade especially at
this one because it eats up a lot of the
storage just just the operating system
there are i think twenty three gigabytes
available on the smaller one free and 83
on the larger one free so you're going
to you know we say 64 and 128 but a big
chunk of that it's going to be eaten up
by just the budget the operating system
yeah and it is expandable it has a USB
desert and it has
a microSD card slot in it so you can add
expansion cards to it if you want to
anyway it is available now this weekend
in stores for the first time so you can
go try it out one of Microsoft stores or
one of the retail partners I think we
have them in the airport even really the
kiosk yeah they've got they've got
airport are you flying somewhere are you
flying somewhere ah no I'm not not
physically you're gonna be flying not
this weekend Oh s T so that's a good
impulse buy you know maybe pick up like
some granola bars a couple of pairs of
like cheap headphones and a bottled
water you have to get that past security
yeah right not if you get it before
they'll make you thought away if you
take this new security what are they
going to tell you I don't know if
they'll make you pull it out or not you
know you don't have to pull the ipad i
would assume you don't have to pull this
one out but would have to pull this one
out but i may be wrong well I mean
technically it's you know the same thing
right there's no moving parts there's no
hard drive right true all right well
Louie so report back to this tell us
what T sa tells you about your their
surveys with windows 8 pro professional
all right Robbie's here hi and he's
brought with him the new blackberry z10
smartphone and apparently they also
brought your jackhammer yeah my dad
can't retained it outside digging holes
for gold we're digging for gold you
could probably hear it over our
microphones but the whole room is
vibrated right now so I'm just going to
assume that the reason it's vibrating is
because if not because of the jackhammer
because you have the blackberry saying I
do I have the blackberry z10 this is
it's running blackberry 10 which is
blackberry used to be called rim so now
you see black bear like 30 times in a
row this is there this is kind of their
saving grace they fell behind the iphone
android even windows phone if you can
believe that okay and now they're coming
back they have the z10 it took them a
year to get this thing out and they
better hope people are buying it it's
actually a pretty good phone that the
hardware is solid it's not it doesn't
feel cheap so it has that going for it
so it's mostly metal it's mostly as a
nice textured back it's kind of like a
rubberized feel doesn't slip from your
hand when you're running from one
meeting to another which is kind of
black
his core audience is the business man in
the business woman running now we did
business did the business the business
persons all go out buy iphones in the
four years they've been waiting for this
damn thing to come out a lot of them did
and so that's that's that's that's why
this is this phone and this operating
system are so important for the company
if they can't get those business folks
back or at least stop the bleeding that
the truck companies in huge trouble and
you know it is like i said it's a nice
phone the operating system is really
nice it's it's closer to android and
iphone then let's say the windows phone
but it has its own little features it
has the hub it has balanced elect that
allows you to have your business and
your personal OS like it's like separate
accounts so the OS is nice it's you know
she exchanged works with exchange which
is active sync so basically it's
everything you'd expect yeah it's are
they expect line and up in a good phone
it's it's it's the best phone they've
ever made as far as i'm concerned but
there's also the app issue and they have
more apps in microsoft windows the
windows phone but who cares it's it's
nowhere near iphone or android and some
of the big apps that you know they
talked about instant i'm sorry mr. Daly
are do they don't have instagram that's
it that's a big bummer but they're gonna
have our do and kindle and some EA games
but are you and Kendall are not here yet
i guess the argument is that it's not
going to make a big difference in the
business world right if it doesn't have
the things like Rdio and and it doesn't
have you know instagram but also people
are going to want to carry this around
they're not going to want to carry on
something else that has that stuff on it
exactly yeah and that's that's that's
the deal i'll know a lot of people who
are hardcore blackberry users who
finally switched to the iphone to
android because their friends had
instagram and their friends had all
these little apps that blackberry didn't
have in BlackBerry's really trying to
get those developers to create stuff for
them they've been knocking on doors
they've been hassling like big game
developers middle like everybody just
make stuff they've gone all out trying
to get developers for this so they're
really trying the thing is is it is it
going to pay off and and the biggest
issue right now for me especially in the
US market is that this phone the z10
their touch screen won't launch until
March probably even late mark
which is two months after their event
the q10 which is their touch that you
know that the cornea people yeah it's
like the blackberry bold but with with a
blackberry 10 on it it won't launch
until probably may even late May which
is like another five months so for me
that's that's the big thing like
everybody I know who still owes a
blackberry and insists on carrying the
role blackberry says the same thing
which is why I have to have the keyboard
and blackberry has a really nice
keyboard to which I say it's 2013 get
over 40 I hate physical keyboard sorry
but I really do say that to them uh but
you know are those people going to be
won over by the new blackberry if it's
just sort of like the same if you're a
park or blackberry user you're going to
be you're going to be happy with this
okay because it's going to do all the
things if you want that keyboard you
have to wait until May a lot of those
people are getting their their
BlackBerry's from their companies so
there you know it might not even be up
until May so there you know the way to
the company to do yeah they'll be get in
November they might be getting in this
summer so that you know is the the
priority for blackberries they get this
thing out for the the regular consumer
and business users who have already
switched over from physical keyboards
speaking of which how much and I'm what
carriers verizon yes there it there's
there's the delay is because of the
carriers there's no pricing there's no
availability and that that is going to
kill them it's doing Corey according to
to blackberry this to get 200-300
dollars probably two-year contract right
around you know the average smartphone
it's not you know so I could be crazy
expensive but it's not going to be like
a $99 foam but without you know numbers
and dates and without that it's it's a
hard sell for a consumer especially in a
quickly moving you know the smartphone
market just is just flying all the time
yeah June's phones are better than
January's phones yeah so big ? on the
blackberry z10 for now Robbie you're
going to have a full review of that up
within the next week or two get wired so
you can look forward to that we'll have
some more video with your final
impressions after you've had a chance to
spend some time with it and we should
have now we should mention this was
announced last week
were travelling I well I wish I wasn't
here last week I missed a show so that's
that's why you're hearing about it now
but it is so far so good but still who
knows what lies at the end of the tunnel
we do know what lies next week which is
us again we'll be back next week with
more lies and truth and gadgets and all
sorts of other things from the gadget
lab